[Musique]
qu'ils soient rouge jaune bleu vert ou
encore espagnols l'oignon et le légume
le plus cuisiner dans le monde c'est une
garniture aromatique naturel dans tous
les plats de la cuisine du monde donc il
va apporter une saveur sucrée du piquant
il va relever les plats sari hausse ont
fait tout un plat pour manger les
oignons crus les meilleures variétés
serait
l'oignon rouge il a une saveur très
sucré très douce donc facile à manger et
plus agréable en bouche tout simplement
un plat de base pour mettre en valeur
l'oignon rouge et la salade grecque
composée de thomas concombres poivrons
et bien sûr d'oignons rouges on va le
coupé perpendiculaire à noter non plus
donc on va les mains sont
donc plus ou moins grosses au dépend des
goûts ça on peut l'ajouter à notre
scinde à la bonne franquette
[Musique]
mais quel est donc le secret qui rend
l'union si populaire essentiellement
lannion est magnifique pour son odeur à
cause de toutes les composés soufrés qui
contient c'est à dire qu'il ya du
souffle dans la molécule naturellement
la aline est à la base de toutes les
molécules qu'on reconnaît comme
aromatiques bande l'oignon la line se
trouve dans le liquide à l'intérieur des
cellules des agneaux mais dans ces
cellules là il ya aussi une grosse poche
qui contiennent de l'eau du sucre et des
enzymes et cette enzyme bloque la ligne
quand on brise les cellules rentrent en
contact avec la lienne et pouf ont
déclenché toute une série de réactions
cette série de réactions chimiques
donnera un goût différent à l'oignon
selon la manière de le couper donc si on
a un couteau qui est super bien futé et
on fait une coupe prat mais on brise
moins de cellules donc si je prends ici
et que je coupe je viens d'endommager
cette partie là donc si je vais ciselés
des oignons toutes les surfaces que j'ai
exposé il ça va permettre la réaction
enzymatique je le sent déjà
en rappant l'oignon on allemande cette
réaction enzymatique ça ça va donner
beaucoup plus de puissance beaucoup plus
de présence à lannion par contre ça ici
si on n'utilise pas rapidement il ya des
composés qui vont s'est créé et qui vont
former de l'amertume
à la cuisson l'oignon des voies d'autres
saveurs de beaux exemples sont la soupe
à l'oignon et la pissaladière le point
de départ la caramélisation l'oignon
quand il est en cuisson il va perdre son
côté piquant et on va les chercher donc
le côté plus sucrés que contient toutes
les oignons dans la poêle un peu de
corps gras ouais donc un petit peu
d'huile canola c'est bien parfait hockey
et on complète avec un petit peu de sel
donc j'en met tout de suite en début de
cuisson le ciel va permettre de dégorger
mes oignons sortir l'eau dû rapidement
et ainsi travailler mehsud emma
canalisations plus rapidement le feu
éteint le feu leur il en est à feu assez
vif mais pas maximum pour éviter de
brûler lot un père furent à nouveau la
coloration on ira à placer un couvert
par dessus pour récupérer les cibles et
qu'ils sont et la belle couleur caramel
une fois cuit l'oignon dégagent tous ses
arômes sucrés comme avec cet exemple
d'un oignons cuits entier ça sent un peu
lannion mais ça sent plus le côté sucré
de l'oignon lannion a beaucoup de sucre
psychose du glucose fructose environ 5 à
8% et donc c'est ça qui va nous
permettre de faire peut-être une des
utilisations les plus répandues qui est
des agneaux ont dit caramélisées mais
c'est là qu'on va faire ressortir
peut-être les justificatifs numéro 1 des
agneaux pour aller dans les plats de
viande si tu sens que tu vas trouver
toutes les notes sont rôties presque
viande est un petit peu dans le
champignon et ça c'est juste des agneaux
n'y a même pas de corps gras là dedans
non parce que c'est étonnant ça sent le
roussi de bottes palette potter venir
que de l'oignon et d'ailleurs il ya une
synergie qui s'est fait quand on facture
des agneaux avec l'avion
[Musique]
cette brillante depp pour démontrer les
variations aromatiques eric a préparé
trois bouillon de viande sans aucun
assaisonnements et quid de la même façon
le avec oignons caramélisés le suivant
avec oignons crus et l'autre sans
oignons alors c'est un bouillon note
un peu bien des mais c'est pas très
aromatique c'est plus une mamie
ici à l'umami on va rajouter bien sûr le
sucre des oignons et là on a des notes
souffre et voilà ça goûte plus la viande
aussi étrangement ça rehausse certaines
mosquées bouillon de poulet
mais quand on en plus avec les sucs on
les fait réagir pour faire la réaction
de maillard mais là on va avoir vraiment
des notes brut si
c'est évident alors oui pour la petite
salade hier on va travailler que
l'oignon blanc il va caramélisées plus
rapidement que l'oignon jaune donc pour
ça je les choisis aujourd'hui puis pour
être frappe à dublin pour l'occasion par
action on va privilégier un oignon jaune
pour une cuisson longue le parfum va se
diffuser il va infuser dans notre
bouillon on va aller chercher quelque
chose d'intéressant je vais ajouter à ce
moment là mais en choix et les olives
dans le mélange juste pour leur donner
un petit coup de chaleur
un peu de sel un peu de poivre puis on
dépose le mélange sur la pâte feuilletée
avant d'enfourner on n'hésite pas en
garni bien des oignons c'est bon pour la
santé
et voilà et quand on est prêts on envoie
le tout au four
[Musique]
enfin pour compléter la soupe à l'oignon
un peu de vin rouge à hauteur qu'on
laisse réduire puis un fond de volaille
on se fait un bon fond c'est goûteux et
on s'en sert pour venir donc mouillé
donc pas l'oignon et encore une fois je
vais mouiller à hauteur de mes oignons
on est généreux sur les croûtons et bien
sûr sur le fromage mais sait on voit ces
trois applications tout ça mais à
laquelle les oignons vont donner tout
leur sens exactement il ya des milliers
de façons les apprêter ça donne de la
saveur des plats
je suis content qu'on se soit mêlé de
bons jeunes hosono